So what is Creole?
And what I'd like to
do is to look at, say,
what happens in the
history of learning French
by adults and by children.
We saw examples of that before.
But what we find there,
and this is actually
a very robust fact,
which is that when
you have people
learning French, often--
so in the case of,
say, object pronouns,
they do produce
structures of that sort.
This doesn't have to be
in the Creole environment.
It happens in
Marseilles, it happens
in all kinds of
varieties where you
have second-language learning.
So the idea is that often,
as you learn the language,
you might see a
particular order,
like subject, verb, object.
If that order is
the dominant order,
often you take that
order and you apply it
to all the elements
that might fit it.
You overgeneralize.
Children do that all the time.
When children say things
like, I have one foot
and you have two foots.
Saying "foot" and
"foots" instead
of saying "foot" and "feet."
It's missing that--
almost every child
will get to do in the
path of learning English.
Because what do they do?
They are real scientists.
They have an hypothesis
about, say, plurals.
S marks the plural.
So why should you
bother to say "feet"
is you have a well-behaved
plural like S.
If you say, I don't know, if
you say "table," "tables."
If you say "pen," "pens."
Why would you say
"foot," "feet"?
[INAUDIBLE] And
children do that.
And the same here.
If you know that your language
has verb object order, you say,
frapp** la balle, hit the ball.
Why would you say, when
you have a pronoun,
why would you put
it before the verb?
It seems to be a
natural hypothesis,
if you're a learner, to assume
that a pronoun like a full noun
will come after the verb.
And that's what you see.
The contrast is between
standard French,
where you get the pronoun before
the verb, and this is as to if.
This is a learner's
French, an adult learner's
French, where you get the
pronoun after the verb.
Not to make a long story
short-- go ahead Nick.
NICK: I don't know.
Maybe it's just off topic.
If it's the most
natural thing to assume
that the object
follows the verb,
how did French ever
develop this weird--
MICHEL DEGRAFF: That's
a good question.
It means that as you
learn the language
there are other factors
in that learning.
Although the learning might
have a natural tendency
to do that, but since,
in the case of French,
there are norms.
There are books, there is TV.
So eventually, the learner will
move towards a different set
of patterns.
But then, languages do change.
And in language
change, often there
is a path towards more general--
Take for example, so Steven
Pinker, a very good linguist
who was at MIT
and at Harvard, he
has a whole book on how the
patterns of regular verbs
change in English.
Things like go, went
or shine, shown.
So many of these over
time become regular.
So you go from shine,
shown to shine, shined.
Well, it hasn't happened yet.
But what he said,
over time there's
a movement of verbs
going from being
irregular to being regular.
And one could explain
that because of the fact
that there's a tendency to
make all these verbs fit
the same pattern,
the regular pattern.
Whereas in time, there's
also prescriptive norms.
There is a prestige language.
There's a linguist
called Tony [? Krock, ?]
who actually argued
that very often, changes
occur in a different
direction because why?
Because people use language
to show that they are fancy,
they are sophisticated.
So they will use the
irregular pattern to show off.
It's like the who, whom case.
So how many of you hear
people saying, "whom" in all
the wrong places, because--
[LAUGHTER]
--because whom,
when you say "whom"
or when you say "John and
I," it might sound fancier
than "John and me."
But what you find
is that often people
will say "John and I" or "Mary
and I" in the wrong place.
They will say, I just had a
good talk with "Mary and--
no-- my dad went to
see "Mary and I."
But "Mary and I" in
that particular context
is not correct.
It should be "Mary and me"
because it's the object.
Why would you say "Mary
and I" in object position?
Maybe because "Mary
and I" sounds sincere
people would tend to use it.
Or the "whom" thing.
We saw earlier that
there are cases
where people say "whom," which
grammatically is not correct.
But because it sounds fancy, so
"whom" should I say is calling?
I hear that all the time.
People say "whom" calls you?
"Whom" calls you?
It should be "who" called you?
Because, according
to the grammar
of the language in that
particular environment,
it's a subject.
So you don't expect
to get "whom"
because "whom" is for
"who," technically,
in terms of grammar,
like "him" is for "he,"
or like "her" is for "she."
This is basically the
function of the m on whom.
It makes it an accusative form.
But yet, people now use "whom"
even when it's a subject.
Why?
Because it sounds fancy.
In fact, there's a
linguist that calls it
a various, a grammar various.
You get infected because
you want to sound fancy.
In fact, we talked
about identity,
that's one place where identity
might play a role in language
change because by using
those forms you want
to project yourself
as being superior,
as being sophisticated.
And then you would use-- it's
like in Creole, in Haitian
Creole, people use often the
rounded vowels from French
to show that they know French.
They use the rounded vowels,
like "euh" instead of "ee"
where it doesn't belong.
And they produce all kinds
of weird sentences, where
you get all these "euhs" where,
even in French you have "ee."
Because they perceive
that the "euh"
is a mockery of
French not Creole.
And therefore they want to
use it all over the place.
And it's called
hyper correction.
You're hyper
correcting yourself.
But as you hyper correct
you sound stupid really.
And then there are all
these jokes about it,
actually, because people
are aware that people
who use all these "euhs"
is because that we
know where to use the "ee."
It's a pressure of
society on speaking
in a particular way
that actually creates
all kinds of weird patterns
that eventually can
become part of the language.
That's one driving
force in language change
is this desire to sound
better than you or I.
It's like people
who vote for Trump.
They might vote for Trump not
because they believe in Trump
but because it might mean
something for their identity.
So language has this power
of establishing status.
STUDENT 5: So when you
struggle with your identity,
are we prone to grammar viruses?
[LAUGHTER]
MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yeah, yeah.
That's one way to
put it, actually.
Yeah.
The next part that I
was going to talk about
had to do with why does
language learning by adults
have this effect on, say,
verb order, on conjugation.
And the point could
be made very quickly,
which is that this is
something which is universal.
That we know, in many
contexts of English learning,
that adults do have
this effect [INAUDIBLE]
If you are going to learn, say,
Italian, or any other languages
that have lots of markers
on a verb for conjugation,
often in the first stages of
learning, you don't have these.
You drop these because you're
trying to speak the language.
And these are to be memorized.
And at first, you may not
memorize them properly.
So it seems that it's
a general phenomenon.
And the point here is that--
the key paragraph
here is this one.
That maybe the way to
understand language change,
which in my view,
includes Creole formation,
is to consider the effects
of both language learning
by adults and by children.
And if that's the
case, then that's
what is going to drive all
kinds of language change,
not just what you see in the
case of Creole formation.
So this is under the
part of the conclusion.
Just to recapitulate
that, basically,
so to those of you
who were asking, So
what's my theory of
Creole formation?
I don't need one.
You see, I don't need one
because Creole formation
is just language change.
So whatever linguists understand
about the way languages change,
to me it applies to
Creole formation.
I have one paper that
came out earlier this year
with Enoch Aboh, my colleague
from Benin from West Africa.
And the paper is called "A
New Theory of [INAUDIBLE]."."
It's new in the
sense that it should
be the default
theory that Creole
are like other languages.
So therefore, you don't need to
have a special theory for them.
So it should be, the
new, like what is this?
That Creoles don't
need a theory.
Whatever theory applies
to French or English
should apply to Creole.